gpt3 is now free to access nvidia
releases gaugan too and it's amazing and
out of google x comes everyday robots
which aims to make robots handle
everyday tasks welcome to ml news
[Music]
hey youtube
hey attention saws what's up uh this
video is sponsored by weights and biases
thank you so much to weights and biases
for being a great sponsor if you don't
know weights and biases you should
definitely check it out it is a one stop
shop for all your machine learning needs
it starts at tracking your experiments
with a single line of code everything is
logged to the cloud your environment is
logged your outputs are logged your
models and data sets can be saved and
iterated upon and it's with you from
conception of your idea all the way to
deployment and monitoring they have
on-prem solutions they have cloud
solutions and it's completely free for
personal use and for academic use so
please try out weights and biases today
i want to highlight their jobs offerings
if you're looking for a job please
consider weights and biases as you can
see right here they have all kinds of
job openings from business operations
customer success there's lots of
engineering jobs there's deep learning
engineers site reliability engineer just
regular software engineer product
engineer infrastructure there's deep
learning engineer for growth but even if
you're not an engineer you can go into
marketing into people operations product
managers all kinds of things and look at
that they just need sales people so if
you're good at selling maybe this is
your position as you can see they have
some jobs in north america some are in
europe but a lot of jobs are actually
remote so whether you enjoy remote work
or on-site work chances are weights and
biases has something for you as you know
as we've reported right here weights and
biases has just raised a giant amount of
money at a one billion dollar valuation
make sure you get a slice of that pie
apply for a job today go to 1db.com go
to resources click on careers and find
all their job offerings right now if
you're not looking for a job check out
their product i'm sure you're going to
love it and thank you so much again to
weights and biases for sponsoring this
video alright let's get into it
openai's blog says the openai api is now
available with no wait list that means
that you can simply go sign up and
you'll get access to the api the api
includes things such as their language
model gpt-3 and so on it includes things
like the instruct models and these
models are good at following things like
instructions and also the codex models
that generate code given a piece of
natural language a function to fill my
bank account
well i guess the model tells me that i
actually need to make a deposit in order
to fill my bank account that's sad of
course the flagship models are still the
gpt models specifically gpt3 the largest
version is called davinci the best idea
ever is
the best idea ever is the idea that is
most useful to the most people thank you
da vinci is a utilitarian absolutely
based so even if you've used gpt3 before
and if that was a while back you might
want to check it out again because the
documentation has involved there are a
lot of examples openai themselves have
figured out a lot more about how to
prompt these models in order to get good
completions in order to actually make
them do what you want them to do and
there's a lot of useful stuff right here
i've actually made a poll about this in
the past and over 1 000 of you have
responded and it turned out most of you
didn't have access yet even though a
large portion of you applied early so to
all of you who still don't have access
this should help you now this doesn't
come as a surprise as in recent times
we've seen a lot of competitors to open
ai simply giving people access to their
api and not having them on a long wait
list so how much of this is well we
finally figured it out and how much of
it is please don't go to our competition
we don't know that being said open ai
still wants to have a very tight control
over people that actually use the api to
build products they say our work also
allows us to review applications before
they go live monitor for misuse support
developers as their product scales and
better understand the effects of this
technology essentially they want to
avoid at all costs that you build a
product that in any way reflects
negatively on open ai be that if the
model makes some sort of a mistake or if
the technology is used for a use case
that maybe isn't super pr friendly that
is not good or bad it's just something
you have to keep in mind when you go all
in and build actually an application on
the basis of an api like this
nvidia releases the second iteration of
their gao gan model which is a
generative adversarial network that
doesn't just come up with stuff by
itself but can be conditioned on certain
inputs gauguin 1 was already being used
to condition the model on sketches as
you see here you can give a bunch of
segmentation maps and then the model
would dynamically adapt and generate a
picture based on that gaugin 2 takes
this a step further now you can also
condition on words for example in fact
they have released a little web app and
as you can see you can condition on a
segmentation map that's what we saw in
gal gan1 you can condition on a sketch
you can condition on a base image or on
text and not only either or of these
modalities but you can mix them all as
you want there is a reddit post by the
user whiskey and some of the pictures
that this user was able to generate were
simply text prompts if i understand this
correctly are just stunning by
themselves so here is a winter mountain
landscape near sunset now interesting is
what you can do this is a stream given a
text description then you can have the
web app generate a sketch from that now
i'm in dark mode right here but you can
probably see the dark lines that are
supposed to be a sketch this is
generated from that image and then based
on the sketch you can re-render with a
different text description or with the
same text description but apply a
certain style to it so there's a lot of
possibilities with models like this you
can explore that in the web app so as
we've said for example we can tell the
model to input text right here so input
utilization text says all that's used is
this text right here i've put far from
home and if i render this which is the
arrow on the right you can see a certain
image is generated if i put close to
earth a different image is generated a
road with trees
in fall that works out pretty well so
what i can do now is i can take that and
copy it over to the left side the left
side is kind of like the input area
before we copy actually let me just take
kind of a pencil and just sketch a bunch
of things here so let me sketch
some
i have no i i have a touch pad don't
don't criticize me uh
and then like a line here okay and we'll
do like some squiggles
here
that is a beautiful sketch so now we can
activate not only text but sketch so now
we're looking for a road with trees and
fall given this sketch well okay i have
to admit my sketch wasn't exactly
something that the model could make
sense of so let me try again just a few
broad strokes right here maybe one here
and
something harsh here
still no my sketching abilities might
not be super good
so let me try the segmentation map for
the segmentation map you wanna take a
brush like this one you want to activate
the input utilization of segmentation
and then here you can select a bunch of
segmentation things so dirt let's put
some dirt here on the lower right hand
corner like this let's also put a bunch
of grass over here
and
how about a
fence
right here
that is a fence fence goes here and then
house
the house is supposed to be take
this part right here i'm not sure how
the model's gonna make this into a house
let's just have the house be all of this
and we generate
okay
if you have better drawing skills than
me feel free but what is cool is that
let's say we generate this image again
right we can then copy that image over
to the left to this input area and then
we can use different variants for
example here we can have the
segmentation map computed from that
image or we can have the sketch computed
from that image so let's compute the
segmentation map from that image
automatically and we can turn off the
visualization of the real image so we
only have the segmentation map left we
can then use that segmentation map
together with the piece of text but now
we're going to change the piece of text
how about a road with trees in spring so
what we want is a similar image but in
spring look at that so this is pretty
cool it would have probably be even more
accurate if we used the source image as
an image which you can also do you can
use a sketch as i said any combination
of these things this web app is pretty
cool and it can even apply custom styles
to images and so on now i don't want to
bore you too much with this and my poor
drawing skills you go ahead and try it
out i'll link it in the description
[Music]
everyday robots is a new initiative
company i have no idea what the actual
legal structure of this is yet i guess
it is some sort of a company and the
goal is to make robots do everyday tasks
so instead of having robots like boston
dynamics where you have very
specifically tailored robots and they're
often hard-coded to do certain things so
for example if a boss dynamics robot
stands backflip this has been the result
of massive engineering effort these
robots are supposed to be a little more
as they themselves say boring yet live
in the real world so they are able to
navigate around obstacles interact with
real things the challenges here are
massive like how do you generalize to
arbitrary settings and environments and
things are dynamic and a lot of things
are happening so this is born out of
google x which is one of their sort of
incubators and if i understand correctly
these robots are already used in some of
their internal cafes here you see one
cleaning of the tables now even with
something as simple as cleaning off the
tables you have to get to the table you
have to see if the table is empty you
have to be able to move around the table
and wash it down correctly until
everything is washed and so on
definitely not an easy task so there's a
big website with a lot of scroll jacking
animations as you can see here but it
seems like a pretty exciting initiative
there's also a good article on wired
about it with a lengthy description of
what the goal here is and what the
capabilities of these robots are right
now and where this company wants to go
one specialty seems to be that these
robots learn relatively quickly for
example teaching them to open a door
apparently took under 10 hours now that
seems like a lot but in real life
reinforcement learning with actual
robots that need to do this safely and
cannot simulate and so on this is
actually a very very short time and once
the robots have acquired this knowledge
they can transmit it to all the other
robots so only one of them technically
has to learn it the company imagines
that in the future these robots will
assist humans with tasks as you can see
here menial labor tasks such as cleaning
off tables and of course since they are
robots the advantage is that they can
for example go into hazardous
environments in general operate
differently than humans they also say
that in the future it might be
supernatural to interact with robots
like these even if it may seem a little
bit dystopian or futuristic right now
google ai presents met net 2 which is
another weather forecasting model so
we've already seen deep mind going into
now casting which means predicting rain
a few minutes up to like two hours from
now and met net one has done previously
work predicting a few hours ahead like
six hours or so if i understand
correctly but now they've pushed this to
12 hours so the different categories of
rain forecasting actually bring a lot
different challenges to them for example
to predict the weather for the next 14
days you look at entirely different
things you look at like big patterns and
you can make some sort of large scale
forecasts you know in the north it's
going to rain in the south it's not
going to rain however that information
is almost completely useless for
something like now casting where you
want extremely local predictions that
are very very accurate in time and in
this regime where net 2 is in the 12
hour region you sort of have to fuse
both of them together you have to look
at very very large areas so for example
here the blue area if i understand
correctly is the area that they actually
look at to make a prediction for the red
area this is a giant area but they still
make predictions on a super fine-grained
resolution i think the resolution here
is a resolution of two kilometers so
every two kilometers they make a
prediction 12 hours from now will it
rain or won't it rain the challenges
from met net one which could only
predict up to like six hours is that in
order to predict for a longer horizon
they have to take more context into
account as you can see right here and
surprisingly one way to do it is to
actually replace the attention layers of
net one with convolutional layers which
are more computationally efficient
however since convolutional layers only
care about their local neighborhoods
they actually use dilated convolutions
to dramatically increase the size of the
receptive fields of convolutions over
just a few layers on their blog you can
see a few examples and comparisons of
their method to other methods and they
even have an investigation into what the
model actually learns about weather
using interpretability tools all of this
is really cool because weather
prediction used to be done with very
very compute intensive physics
simulation which took apparently about
one hour in order to make this same
prediction that met net 2 makes in under
one second so invite you to go check out
the blog post if you wanna learn more
a cool project by nathaniel felike on
hackster.io is this tiny ml dog bark
stopper so this is a report on how to
use things like arduinos and speakers in
order to detect when a dog barks and
when the dog barks to play an
appropriate sound apparently this dog
has a bit of separation anxiety so
whenever the owner leaves the house the
dog just kinda goes wild and this video
is a description on how they've used a
speaker that is coupled to an arduino
that records sound that the dog makes
classifies the dog's sound into barking
or not barking this is done converting
the sound into spectrograms and then
classifying those spectrograms and then
when a bark is detected the speaker will
play a pre-recorded sound of the owner
such that the dog thinks that the owner
is still there so i very much invite you
to go check it out if you want to build
something like this for yourself i'm
sure this is a very good basis in order
to do so the instructions are all there
and if you're into the mixture of ml and
actual real world hardware a little bit
into soldering and hacking this might be
for
you speaking of hardware and interacting
with machine learning this is an
ambitious project where the youtube user
stack smashing has used a video capture
card combined with again i think an
arduino or a raspberry pi in order to
get a ml model to drive mario kart
usually this is done in an emulator
people have done this before learn to
drive mario kart using machine learning
however this user does it on an actual
console which means that they read out
the picture that the console generates
using a capture card they feed that
image into a neural network and then
they use this raspberry pi in order to
send the commands back to the console
now the system doesn't go as far as
actually move a joystick on a controller
but they do send the appropriate
controller inputs to the console using
sort of like a cut-off cable and then
sending the inputs to the cable the
project details how they've adapted the
tensor card project that is meant for an
emulator and brought it to essentially
the real world mario kart with the
console the machine learning part of the
project isn't very complicated the user
has done a bunch of manual runs recorded
their controller inputs and then let the
model learn from those controller inputs
a few challenges that arise there is
that usually humans steer very abruptly
and this user has purposefully as you
can see here try to only steer super
duper smoothly such that the model has a
better target distribution to learn that
is not as noisy at the end the model is
able to learn the track that it has been
trained on and interestingly it also can
drive a little bit on tracks that it
hasn't been trained on though not all of
the tracks so if you think this is cool
and you want to learn more go over to
stack smashings youtube channel and
check out the video i'll link it in the
description
nbc new york writes new york city aims
to be the first to arraign in artificial
intelligence hiring tools this is about
new legislation in new york city that
would ban employers from using automated
hiring tools unless a yearly bias audit
can show they won't discriminate based
on applicants race or gender they
compare this to another rule that the
city has enacted that restaurants have
to display a calorie count with their
menus and the article here goes into the
detail of what the advantages and
disadvantages are and that some people
think that it doesn't go nearly far
enough now the whole crux of the matter
here of course is that what does this
yearly bias audit contain what does it
mean that you won't discriminate based
on an applicant's race or gender you can
interpret this very strictly where if
the model doesn't have access to the
applicant's race or gender it cannot
possibly discriminate based on that yes
the argument usually goes that there are
correlates to race or gender and models
very often make decisions based on those
correlates however what's the definition
of based on on the very other end of the
spectrum you can essentially say that
any system that has any disparate
outcome whatsoever with respect to
hiring fails this yearly bias audit it's
interesting that with such a simple
piece of legislation you can get into
very deep discussions about nature
versus nurture what is fixed about
people what isn't how are decisions made
even in humans and what does it mean to
make a decision based on something i
mean there are a lot of interesting
questions to be had right here and i'm
pretty sure none of the people who
actually passed the ruling have ever
dived into it it just sounds good oh yes
let's make a rule ai systems cannot
discriminate based on race and gender
that sounds good think of the children
the article also says that a good
outcome of this is a part of the
legislation that says that the company
has to disclose if it uses automatic
systems to screen you i'm not sure what
you're going to do with that as an
applicant at the end of the day i guess
the question is you know of course we
all feel the kind of disgust being
evaluated by an ai system and then being
rejected for some arbitrary algorithmic
rule but i'm not sure like we seem to
all pretend that hr personnel is a lot
different it's not like an hr person
that has a stack of a thousand resumes
for like three positions is going
through each of them deeply delving into
the applications and really grappling
with every person individually no
they're gonna look at it school i don't
know gone bad grades gone gap in
whatever year something gone i mean i
feel we're comparing ai tools to
unreachable master standards whereas i
think what we should be doing is
comparing them to what's already there
and what's already there most often
isn't working either now the people that
criticize this they say that is not
going far enough say that essentially
the bill was watered down so that it
effectively just asks employers to meet
existing requirements under us civil
rights law prohibiting hiring practices
that have a disparate impact based on
race ethnicity or gender oh no how
terrible you're only asked to comply
with the law i mean that is a shame
clearly this isn't far enough right if
you're interested check out this article
and tell me what what you think about
these questions
[Music]
justdrinks.com analysis which beverage
companies are leading the way in
artificial intelligence
yes
that is that is what i needed in in my
pepsi just just a bit more ai in that
can like oh wow the drink is now also a
recommender system yes please apparently
after putting your coffee through the
portafilter starbucks now also forward
propagates it through a convolutional
neural network before serving it to you
or maybe they use rl to finally get
customers names right who knows but it
lets me sleep well at night to know that
the beverage companies they're really on
this ai stuff because it really like
that is going to make the difference
here
deepmind google brain and the chess
champion vladimir kramnik have published
a paper called the acquisition of chess
knowledge in alpha zero they investigate
alpha zero i've previously made a video
on alpha zero about what alpha zero
learns about chess and it's quite
interesting so the paper is fairly
lengthy and investigates not only how
alpha zero thinks but also what are the
overlaps with how humans play chess how
are human concepts that you know that
grandmasters pay attention to when they
play chess how are they represented in
the alpha zero system and are they
represented at all so they do a lot of
different analyses which is really
interesting and they also have an
accompanying website where you can
investigate a little bit into that stuff
for example they have different
non-negative matrix factorizations of
the different board positions
non-negative matrix factorization is an
excellent tool where you can see how
different components additively combine
to form certain structures they also let
you select given board positions and
then track how the different systems
react to that board position and what
continuations there are and you're able
to compare alpha zero during training
right here with humans over the years
since 1985-ish
so the assumption here is that humans
have gotten better over time and maybe
we can compare a little bit new
strategies that were discovered by
humans with new strategies that alpha
zero discovers as it becomes better
using self-play now i've investigated
this a little bit and honestly i haven't
found really a big overlap here but i'm
also not super good at chess so uh don't
take my word for it
alright some helpful things for this
week there is a rudali which we
previously reported about it's a russian
version of dali that is trained on
emojis now you might think that is
ridiculous to which i would respond to
with a crying face emoji however the
results are actually pretty cool like
look at this for saint basil's cathedral
looks pretty neat there's donald trump
from lego a human eats an apple i mean
given that people already use emojis a
lot when texting you can totally imagine
a future where you cannot just select
from the emojis that are given to you
but that sort of emojis would be created
on the fly and maybe you could choose
from 10 emojis that are conditioned on
the sentence you just wrote and then you
can select among those seems pretty neat
honestly i know it doesn't solve world
hunger but
could be useful open code blocks is a
project that is similar to jupiter
notebooks except that you're able to
connect cells not linearly but as a
graph so if this data format flourishes
it's no longer necessary to tell people
well first you gotta run cell one and
then cell two and only run cell three if
you want this run self or twice and so
on this format abstracts all of this
into a dag if i understand this
correctly and you can then run these
cells individually or you can run like
one strand of these cells seems pretty
cool the project is quite young so if
you want to get into this you have to be
ready for kind of like alpha version
software but it might be a very very
cool project to contribute if you're
into tooling tensorflow has a new
library for graph neural networks now
tensorflow has made a bunch of attempts
previously at graph neural networks and
related things i remember things like
tensorflow fold and stuff like that but
this now seems to be a pretty
sophisticated library for doing graph
neural networks so you're able to define
various architectures and then run your
message propagation algorithms in a way
where you can also back propagate
through it the examples show how to
build easy graph neural networks given
predefined functions on edges and nodes
and also how to build graph neural
networks that have custom functions for
that so pretty cool check out the github
repo if you're into graph neural
networks and you're using tensorflow
this might be a very good library for
you keep in mind that this is also an
alpha release but should get better in
the future high dreamer is a torch
implementation of the dreamer v2
reinforcement learning algorithm the
original dreamer v2 is implemented in
tensorflow and this is essentially a
port to pytorch now the features differ
somewhat and the implementations differ
somewhat so the results aren't exactly
the same but it could be a cool baseline
if you want to experiment with dreamer
like reinforcement learning algorithms
you can see right here sometimes it does
better sometimes it does worse than the
original dreamer implementation but i
guess that's just reinforcement learning
so if you're interested the project has
quite an extensive readme to get you
started have fun code gen x is a model
that takes in code and spits out what
more code you should write pretty simple
it's a little bit like github copilot
however the difference is that it is
open source there's github repo it's
based on gptj and there is a vs code
extension you can get a free api key and
start using it right away the website is
a bit bare bones right now but looks
pretty cool other than copilot it
currently supports just python though
they say they are planning to add
additional languages in future releases
so very cool project go check it out and
here from devpost this is another
submission from the pytorch annual
hackathon this is the heyo camera now it
currently only exists for mac but this
is a camera plugin that recognizes hand
gestures and then displays appropriate
reactions so this person is happy this
person is not happy this person raises
their hand very excellent this seems a
bit gimmicky but the sort of recognition
of gestures of course cannot only be
used to display simple emojis but can be
used to trigger various other things so
again there is a github page you can
download and install it for mac if you
want or you can continue developing it
and our last story for today idw online
writes the einstein foundation to
present the inaugural 500 000 euro award
for promoting quality in research and
the award in part goes to the founder of
archive so the individual award worth
200 000 euros goes to paul ginspark
professor of physics and information
science at cornell in 1991 he created
the archive a document server for
preprints on which scientific findings
are published without review and paywall
restriction archive has become by far
one of the most valuable tools
especially to the machine learning
community and it's pretty cool to see
its creator recognized for putting this
out there as early as 1991 that is crazy
excellent work thank you all right this
was already it for ml news this week i
hope you had fun did you catch the
gorilla
[Music]
you